c'est un acte où les jurés ça touche pas
à mon pote il est 19h47 on est en direct
m'a énormément de sujets à traiter
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
comme vous voulez en tête jeudi soir il
y à un livreur des numéros qui s'est
présenté à la fenêtre de mon restaurant
oui ben avant que je lui demande le
numéro de commande
il m'a dit c'est quoi comme spécialité
votre restaurant moi naturellement je
lui dis spéciales et des israéliennes
d'accord mais à ce moment là il m'a
regardé et m'a dit ok alors je livre pas
il a pris la tablette qu'il a il a dit
jeanne eu la commande à ce moment là je
lui ai dit mais pourquoi tu annules dieu
je vais pas le cacher ce n'est pas pour
les juifs il est parti le livreur et
bien il était un commis de délits vers
où il travaille pour des libéraux donc
il fallait ne serait ce que pour avoir
une assistance un peu positif de des
livres ou dans le cadre de l'anc est
déposé plainte également contre des
livres ou parole de délits verrou
damiens typhon qui vient de téléphoner à
notre production puisqu'on est en direct
et qui nous a dit qu'il se tenait à
notre disposition demain si on a des
questions à poser et bravo à dd voilà de
réagir aussi vite
si l'auteur des faits est retrouvé et il
ne sera et si les faits sont qualifiés
et je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils ne sont
s'ils sont avérés nous on agira on
mettra un terme à notre coopération
commerciale avec ce prestataire là
d'accord parce que on veut faire je ne
dirais pas qu'on veut faire un exemple
mais on veut qu'il soit très fermement
entendu que pour nous ce genre
d'agissements sont une exception
elle survit nicolas pernikoff et j'ai
une question un moment donné vous les
rémunérer ces gens il n'ya pas de
pillages la question mais vous savez pas
qui sait où voulait pas donner son nom
alors bien sûr que nous savons qu'ils se
sont qui ils sont
moi je naturellement je ne donnerai pas
et bien sûr je suis en tête sur le nord
et bateaux d'occasion vous demande il
faut pas ajouter la vindicte l outrage
bien sûr ces nominations soient le fait
que vous savez vous l'année oui
naturellement après il ya des choses il
faut démêler l'écheveau quoi si vous
voulez donc
l'émotion de tout le monde elle est
légitime et on la partage on veut faire
les choses en lien avec la police en
lien avec vous m 10 ans de manière
extrêmement méthodique pour que voilà à
la fin les choses soient soit clair
qu'il ne soit dit et qu'on puisse agir
merci en tout cas des livres où m alors
qu'est ce qui se serait passé selon
votre client alors écoutez mon client
était en train de déjeuner
tranquillement dans un restaurant il a
été pris à partie par ces individus qui
ont demandé de ranger son téléphone
évidemment il n'avait pas sorti faux
contextualiser jo et bédié à 65 ans
c'est pas un aficionado des anges de la
télé réalité
il ignore tout en réalité de cette
émission est évidemment il a dit que
c'était son droit d'avoir son téléphone
mais ce à quoi une ruée de coups a suivi
il a tué absolument tout de suite vous
verrez que les images que l'on peut voir
de cette agression parle d'elle-même
elle est d'une infinie violence c'est
vrai que on a vu ces images vous les
avez vus également chez vous c'est vrai
que c'est très très très très très
violent il est dit qu'une personne de la
production aurait été très agressive
envers le maire et sa famille
j'ai appris il ya soir et je peux vous
montrer j'ai surmonté les représentants
de l'émission antoine henry quitte pour
qu'ils me racontent producteurs ce qui
s'est passé parce qu'effectivement on
avait une émission qui était
relativement à charge c'est normal
c'était l'avocat déjà bien sûr
aujourd'hui quand même appelé antoine
que je connais bien et que tu vois ce
qui s'est passé email et d'abord ils
étaient extrêmes on ne perdait pas
expliquer tout ce qui s'est passé alors
il sera comptée double mais qui sait
mais ça fait deux heures que donc je
sais moi pas ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé m'a dit
voilà c'est alors ça s'est passé
et voilà la bague est répartie des
premiers boutons a bâti son sang s'est
passé c'est l'histoire de deux photos
ils ont été agacés que les apparemment
les copains et les amis du fils du maire
prenne des photos ça a été assez assez
vindicative dont les propos en disant
ouais vous les décrivez des mères etc
on était dans de plusieurs noms
d'oiseaux peu importe et apparemment les
premiers coups ont été portés n'ont pas
parlé konaté vérité mais parler comme
celle qui sur les côtés c lagarde qui
s'était cognée marquée par le par le
fils du maire voilà il est fait il a
fait un séjour à l'hôpital il a pris une
chaise sur la tête il a une tête
apparemment contusionné donc moi il
m'est - 10 h 10 coûte m'a très bien
comme ça je pourrais leur à compter de
demain chez cyril expliquer ce qui s'est
passé maintenant c'est la version du
producteur il est très embarrassé
un tableau sans connaître une baisse
bears arrière si je vais vous dire ce
qui s'est passé d'événements se faire
parce que je nie tout téléspectateur jeu
le directeur des programmes vincent
pujol qui venaient me voir discrètement
avant l'émission qui m'a dit écoute neil
finn est magnifique
est ce qu elle ne referait pas un petit
défilé alors que lorsqu'elle a été miss
france elle film c'est à vous de choisir
ce qu'on voulait nous faire un petit
défilé pendant ce temps là où la
sélection pas aller j'avais ce qu'il m'a
dit il m'a dit c'est spectaculaire pour
la samba dia sans pujol delphine est ce
que tu es par ton mail srf est parti à
l'onu
sud radio
merci didier d'être là alors oui alors
confinement on n'a pas fait la preuve
que ça fonctionnait s'il est ce que
cette fois c'est ça faire descendre le
noir c'est la seule chose qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui c'est dans cette ville que
denis robert
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire cela
passe chez elle sonne tous les périls et
dans tous les pays qui ont confiné
on voit qu'il ya une baisse des cas sur
une baisse des personnes en réanimation
donc une baisse des décès il ya la
saisonnalité qui joue premièrement c'est
la désobéissance avec ma tête d'abruti
ça veut dire que vous allez dire au
genre alesi sortait fait la fête
vous êtes nous travaillons l'animation
non vous êtes pompiers non c'est vous
qui allez allez allez dans la rue en
tant que policier pour faire régner
l'ordre
non quand vous dites je vais sortir moi
je vais je vais assumer vous allez
sortir vous allez aller ou si tout est
fermé vous avez ou dans la rue pour
prendre 135 euros vous avez les moyens
payés tant mieux pour vous je dis
simplement qu'on est dans une mauvaise
séquence là et que si on continue à se
confiner avec des stop and go on peut
vivre jusqu'à la fin des temps parlé
aujourd'hui ce cas là honnêtement
effectivement on ne sait pas grand-chose
mais faut bien regarder une chose et
elle est évidente c'est que si l'état
l'état est mercantile et cédant monde
entier s'ils font ça c'est mazères par
plaisir de dépenser des milliards et des
milliards de milliards et que quelque
part soit effectivement c'est
extrêmement dangereux et ils n'ont pas
osé ligne et où ils veulent quand ils
veulent pas le dire
oui je vois pas pourquoi le monde entier
la chine angleterre les abonnés les
anglais qui sont qui sont un pays on
peut pas pu me faire le plus libéral que
des anglais les américains
tout le monde est tétanisé vous écoutez
madame écouter fanny qu'est ce qui se
passe alors par jour alors pardon
monsieur ans mais c'est de la barbarie
c'est cruel c'est un être vivant qu'ils
soient domestiques ou qu'ils soient
sauvages c'est cruel
vous aimez les chiens et si on faisait
pareil avec vos chiens ont les épuise
ont leurs cours après ils sont là ils se
couchent sur la voie ferrée les pauvres
et là on tue vos chiens à coups de
couteau parce que ces nobles et parce
que ça fait maintenant une pratique a
été abolie vous vous rendez compte on
parle au danemark et en norvège
au xviiie siècle ça a été aboli en
allemagne en 1934 il a été aboli en
belgique ça a été abolie dans plusieurs
pays pourquoi pas chez nous vous rendez
compte il ya eu des anciens
sur des routes nationales parce qu'il ya
eu d'émeutes ont ils traversé via insère
dans un champ qui a fini en étant
dévorées par des chiens par vos chiens
et vous trouvez que c'est pas barbare
vous trouvez que c'est pas cruel on
parle d'un être vivant
si on faisait ça à vos chevaux et si on
faisait ça à vos chiens vous trouverez
ça normal qu'on termine vos petits
chiens à l'armé blanche alors moi je
l'envié qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors
donc tu te sens soulagé ça faisait 15
juin jour qu'on était en grève de la
faim
quelque chose me choque un peu le
merguez doit maintenant d'accord
stéphane alors raconté mouftah ému la
france entière
aujourd'hui je te sentir je te sens
soulagé en fait ce sont même fatigué tu
sais tu est allé arracher la pression et
bien c'est bien en fait
comment le combat s'est terminé
aujourd'hui le premier combat s'est
terminé autour dû ameuter un soulagement
extravagant en fait parce que là il est
là il est présent enfin c'est vous
aujourd'hui pour enfin pourquoi
aujourd'hui et pas hier enfin vous la
bourse
la situation est propre maintenant tu
fais pour mon fournil et mon travail
mais des situations comme ça c'est hors
norme pour moi
donc en fait ont été très bien reçus
voilà avec avec une finalité un cas
exceptionnel en fait pour le garder
c'est là là il va pouvoir rester en
france c'est ça
[Musique]